dans cette tranche et du dombass ces
soldats ukrainiens se préparent à
défendre la région dans un calme pesant
à d'aussi par le chant printanier des
oiseaux
s'il essaye de prendre cette position je
les étudie ce soldat si je ne peux pas
ils me tueront ce sont les règles de la
guerre le gouverneur de la région
exhorte les civils à partir sans
hésitation ya ce côté
la situation se dégrade dit-il les
chemins de fer ont été bombardés les
infrastructures ont été endommagés
les files de véhicules se dirige vers
l'ouest vers une paix relative laissant
derrière eux des paysages de désolation
et des pro russe qui refuse de croire à
l'invasion thamond feu
poutine est un type bien j'étais en
russie quand j'ai rendu visite à mon
petit-fils au nigeria taxes et autres
femmes croient que le donbass aura
détruit que les américains y
installerons des armes chimiques apporte
une sommation alors que celle-ci blâme
poutine pour la guerre un don basse
divisée dans ses croyances est enlisé
dans la guerre il devient de plus en
plus évident que ce sera une guerre
d'usure qu'elle va durer longtemps le
scénario le plus probable depuis déjà
quelques semaines c'est qu'il y ait une
partition de l'ukraine mais une version
qui ne sera pas reconnue ni par le
gouvernement ukrainien ni par le reste
de la communauté internationale
après plus de quarante jours de guerre
de morts et de destructions le kremlin
reconnaît enfin des pertes
dans une entrevue à sky news le porte
parole du président poutine admet les
difficultés de son armée
[Musique]
il décrit le retrait des troupes de kiev
et de tchernihiv comme un acte de bonne
foi ce n'est que
dans sa cour arrière tetyana résidente
de boudhha montre la tombe de son fils
et de deux de ses amis difficile pour
elle de croire en un acte de bonne foi
je suis moi-même originaire de données
est ce qu j'ai été obligé de partir en
2014 pour sauver la vie de mon fils il
avait alors 14 ans je suis arrivé il est
mort ici comment est ce possible
la houle est trop pour eux sont passés
les corps des victimes du craignait
s'amoncellent thomson annoncé le
président céline ce qu'ils affirment que
la situation à boro diankha et clear cab
ou de chats scénario encore peu aurait
été que la russie réussit à prendre le
contrôle de l'ukraine sans coup férir un
scénario propice à s'arrêter que les
occidentaux ne se porte pas au secours
du tout de l'ukraine qu'il n'a d'aucune
sanction qui ne fournissent pas
d'armements aux ukrainiennes ce soutien
le chef de la diplomatie ukrainienne
aimerait qu'ils soient plus rapides
soit vous nous aidez maintenant et je
parle de jours pas de semaines ou votre
aide arrivera trop tard
ici à ce mitraillage hadj au canada
montréal